Це один із найбільших автоцвинтарів Європи.
70 тисяч квадратних метрів неподалік від Гамбурга.
Понад 2,5 тисячі автоблях.
Величезний мікрокосмос, що функціонує за власними правилами.
Ура, знайшов!
Нарешті знайшов!
Ігровий майданчик для чоловіків.
Тут переважно можна побачити авто середнього класу.
Майже всі на дизелі.
І - в це важко повірити - усі ще на ходу.
Приміром, як ця.
Власник пригнав свій дизельний Волькваґен Пасат для утилізації.
Через наслідки дизельного скандалу в Німеччині
ця автівка коштує тепер лише тисячу євро.
Премія з утилізації значно більша - 7 тисяч євро.
Це, власне, автомобіль, який ще повністю функціонує,
нещодавно пройшов техогляд. Але оскільки я взяв собі машину у лізинг,
цю можна віддати.
Від автозвалища він ще отримає гроші за запчастини.
Ось вам ще 100-єврова купюра. Можете сходити поїсти на широку ногу.
Сім тисяч євро премії з утилізації виплачують, якщо
автовласник віддає свою стару машину і купує собі нову того ж автовиробника.
Автоконцерни в Німеччині виплачують за це до 10 тисяч євро.
Усе це, власне, автомобілі, які ще не конче утилізувати,
вони ще могли б їздити і їздити. Але ця премія з утилізації
настільки приваблива, що автовласники не можуть встояти.
Через таку ласу премію на автозвалищах опиняються
не лише старі розвалюхи, але цілком пристойні і доглянуті автівки,
як, приміром, ось цей Вольксваґен з дизельним двигуном 2006 року випуску.
Запчастини, такі як мотор, перепродають.
Не все опиняється на металобрухті.
Аж боляче, коли бачиш такий автомобіль
з пробігом лише 47 тисяч кілометрів, такий доглянутий.
Звісно, така автівка могла би ще їздити і їздити, вона ще цілком справна.
Після того, як в автомайстерні з авто вийняли ще придатні автозапчастини,
вона переходить в інші руки.
Знімають шини. Ті, на яких ще можна їздити, теж перепродають.
Далі видаляють рештки автомобільного масла, бензину,
охолоджувальну рідину та рідину для очистки скла.
А також акумулятори.
І каталізатори: їх теж можна продати за кілька євро.
За вживані запчастини, знайдені на автозвалищі,
клієнти платять вчетверо менше, ніж за нові.
Моя здобич!
Супер!
Автомобіль складається з понад 10 тисяч запчастин.
Пошук потрібної деталі для своєї автівки може тривати годинами.
Чудово! Це воно! Потрібна деталь!
Я розібрав спідометр на своїй машині,
я із задоволенням копирсаюся в автівках.
Тут справді є багато цілком добрих автозапчастин.
Вживані автозапчастини, які викрутили зі старих автомобілів,
зберігаються на складі.
Ми маємо тут близько 30 тисяч автозапчастин -
від коробок передач і амортизаторів до бамперів і моторів.
Власне, цІле авто.
До кінця робочого дня білий Вольксваґен повністю розібрали.
Каркас готовий до транспортування на металобрухт.
Через кілька місяців він піде під прес і на плавку.